The Birth of a Nation is the ambitious
directorial debut of Nate Parker who
also wrote and stars in this film and
it's the story of nat turner a slave in
the south in the early 1800s who after
witnessing a long series of atrocities
orchestrates an uprising against people
who are committing these atrocities and
this is based on true events loosely and
I say loosely because there's not that
much actually known about the real man
nat turner and so this film does fill in
a lot of the gaps to create more
theatrical storytelling for dramatic
purposes which is common we see that in
tons of movies like Braveheart and
things like that where you don't
necessarily have all the info but you
want to make it fun for the audience to
watch and I was excited to see this
movie because this movie made a
humongous splash at Sundance I've been a
fan of Nate Parker as an actor ever
since I first saw him and there will be
arbitrage I think he's extremely
talented and I think he's somebody who
has a big voice who wants to be heard
who wants to make good films and I was
very curious to see his debut however I
have a hard time with films like this 12
years a slave broke me that movie
disturbed me on such a level that I've
never watched it again I have a really
hard time with films like this because I
loathe racism it's something that I
don't understand it's something that I
just simply can't relate to and so when
I see it in films like this portrayed so
violently I can really have a bad
reaction to it and so I was a little
apprehensive about even going to this
movie plus there's a lot of media
controversy surrounding this actor
director right now because of things
that happen in the past so I was like do
I even really want to see this movie but
I went to see it anyway because it's a
film and something that I've never had a
hard time with is separating the art
from the artist and I think that's very
important whenever a film critic is
reviewing a movie and that's hard to do
in today's society because everyone
wants to talk about everything so it's
hard sometimes to just hone in on the
film but I think I did a pretty good job
12 years a slave as I've said is a film
that really impacted me emotionally it
left me broken physically I felt
slightly stomach sick after seeing that
film oddly this film did not give me
that same reaction similar to 12 years
of slave horrific Aleve Island and
disgusting acts
are committed against innocent people
and you feel for that time in history
and you are angry about it but in 12
years of slave I felt something in the
birth of a nation I have a hard time
connecting with these characters because
the film is very conventional and it
falls back far too often on a lot of
narrative cliches and storytelling
tropes there are a lot of really
impressive things in The Birth of a
Nation namely Nate Parker's performance
as an actor in this film I genuinely
think his performance is oscar-worthy I
think he is incredible in this movie he
gives a very nuanced emotionally damaged
performance and as a performer he
knocked it out of the park where the
film falters is its screenplay and some
of its pacing and the way the film is
directed in regards to scene structure
and harnessing everything to make it
feel like it's all flowing naturally the
character in this movie has such an
abrupt shift from being a preacher who
believes in the Bible to being someone
who wants to lead a revolt and a very
violent revolt in which no mercy is
given to any one men women children it
doesn't matter it's very very horrific
ly violent and it's one of those things
where you expect a little more time to
be given to make this character shift so
much especially if they're already going
to fill in so many gaps with
fictionalized portrayals of events
things happen so abruptly in this film
armie hammer portrays the leader of this
plantation and he's kind of a better
person than the other people who are
enslaving people he's a little bit
kinder it seems like he has NAT Turner's
back and then one day he's just like hey
bring that woman inside she's gonna
sleep with my guest here because I want
my house to be famous again and I was
like where'd this come from it was just
so random so many things like that
happen in this film where characters are
shown to be a certain way and then all
of a sudden like that they just change
drastically with no real reason as a
director Nate Parker does a lot of
really impressive things with the camera
it is a very good looking movie there
are shots that did make my mouth drop
there is some beautiful lush
cinematography in this film and as I
said the performance is really are
strongest part every actor in this film
really brings their a game especially
Nate Parker it's a film that was clearly
made with a lot of passion Nate Parker
put a lot of his own money into this
project and tried to get other people to
help him to make it he didn't want to
act again until he portrayed this
character but it's such a strange choice
because so little is known about this
actual man and what his impact on
history really was that it really is
just a film about some very courageous
people who are doing something that
maybe didn't actually work and the film
doesn't quite touch those emotional
Heights that it should the film should
have been much more tragic than it was
because it tries to sell his revolt as
this big victory when in reality it
didn't actually make the impact that he
was hoping it would and if the film
touched on those tragic events a little
more in the fact that that is just so
horrific Elyse add that it didn't really
work out the way he wanted it to then I
think this film would have been
emotionally impactful in a much greater
way the thing that I appreciated the
most about this movie from a
storytelling perspective is its
examination of the way man can take the
bible or religion and twist it to make
their beliefs seem proper or correct and
that was something that i think should
have been explored a lot more in this
film because he's forced to preach to
slaves only specific verses that make it
seem like slavery is a good thing he's
not allowed to read other verses that
directly contradict that and I wish the
film had discussed that more rather than
falling back on so many cliches of this
type of filmmaking I think Nate Parker
has made a very ambitious film one that
I think people should see at some point
but I don't really think it's as good as
other films that are similar like 12
years of slave it didn't have that
emotion it didn't leave me feeling as
shaken and disturbed and disgusted as 12
years a slave did because I didn't have
that connection with the characters in
this film the tonal shifts were just too
abrupt in some of these characters and
in the structure and pacing there's also
a lot of odd metaphorical imagery that
didn't really work for me but still this
is a very ambitious film that at some
point I think people who appreciate
shade filmmaking should check out I'm
going to give the birth of a nation a c+
could have been a lot better and I think
it was far too overhyped at Sundance I
think this is as I said a film that
deserves to be seen at some point but it
is not that next-level classic that I
was hoping it was going to be guys thank
you so much as always for watching again
sorry some of these reviews were late I
was on vacation actually went in saw
this movie last night
and I was the only person in the theater
that was kind of cool I had the whole
place to myself but I really needed to
sleep on this movie because I did feel
conflicted by it guys thank you once
again for watching and if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you